hello everybody we just hit a hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers and if
you've been following along you know
that's a an incredible amount of
subscribers to get in such a short time
we just hit a hundred thousand
subscribers more On February 6 and it is
now March 6 today depending on what part
of the world you were in and that means
we hit we got 50,000 subscribers in a
month in a month that's like
unbelievable that's more than what I
said that we got in 30 days just a
little bit ago so the pic the pace
actually picked up a huge amount just in
the past few days so I mean thank you
guys so much you know the only thing
that's doing and the only thing that's
really driving this is the fact that you
guys are spreading the word about the
channel and I actually feel bad because
I have nothing to show for it because I
don't have any time I was literally up
well last night I was playing video
games all night I was playing the new
Mass Effect 3 DLC and I lost track of
time for AI news 10 a.m. and I had
nothing to show for it that's why I
threw that little Minecraft compilation
from days gone by that is older than
dirt that is slow those highlights are
sold I had a different microphone back
then I had a different everything back
then I don't even think I didn't have a
webcam some people asking like weird
webcam I didn't have one back then so
that's ancient but I guess it still
works so thank you guys for bearing with
me on that one and no I'm not starting
up more minecraft except for drunk
minecraft coming back soon but anyway
that's all besides the point
mmm the real point is just thank you
guys so much because this is this is
unreal that it's actually happening
before our eyes
because a lot of people will jump into a
channel and they'll see oh he has this
many subscribers he's probably always
had this many subscribers and people
often forget if they haven't seen
something grow throughout the time that
there were these huge periods of just
like sudden rapid expansion and it's all
because of hard work that you guys have
done to help grow the channel and all
that blood and sweat and tears well not
I'm not saying like it's equivalent to
coal mining or anything like that but
it's it's really all the legwork that's
done by the viewers early on that really
drives a channel forward and I can't
thank you guys enough for doing that and
continuing to do that because the growth
has not stopped it it's just launching
upwards and onwards and there's probably
nothing I can do to stop it unless I
suddenly started worshipping Nazis I
pretty sure that you've gotta know dumb
one's gonna cut out that soundbite and
mash together Marc Blair we're super
Nazis so but anyway it's just incredible
what you guys have been able to do and
so I got a I gotta understand that I
need to be able to give back for that so
the charity livestream is this Saturday
starting at 10:00 a.m. and going until
we hit our goal of ten thousand dollars
we're raising it by two thousand dollars
again considering we got a couple ten
thousand more people I'm pretty sure
we'll be able to hit it and I may even
raise the goal after that if I feel like
continuing which I probably will because
you guys have done an incredible job and
III don't want these things to be
exclusively about cancer there's a lot
of diseases that need money raised for
all sorts of different research but for
the moment there was a really touching
comment and people been sending me all
sorts of emails and predominantly they
have mostly been about breast cancer and
I know we already did one but that
doesn't mean that they don't need more
help
there was Breast Cancer Awareness Month
but we got to remember that these needs
don't just happen once a month you got
to give all the time to have any hope of
curing them so it's going we're going
with living beyond breast cancer again
it's the same charity but that's one of
the most highly rated charities I'm
pretty dedicated to only giving putting
these charity drives towards charities
that actually have a good reputation
because I want them to be maximize the
amount of money that goes into these
things so and if I'm going through the
same website against Hill because I
don't want to handle the money
I don't want the legal issue of me
touching that and I don't want you guys
to think that I'm getting gonna give it
at all so it's just more convenient to
do this so everything should be set up
and ready to go hopefully I'll have more
moderators in chat because we may be
pushing 3,000 people in there at once
and that'll be kind of ridiculous don't
know what games were gonna play but I'm
gonna have a full schedule all planned
out for you guys so thank you guys so
much once again you guys have been an
absolute incredible help and you know
it's is you're more you're more than
just numbers to me I always want you
guys to remember that it's a big number
and I'm not gonna delude myself to think
that I can't be personal with anyone but
that doesn't mean that I devalued you
with anyone because I used to sit in you
know class or something and I would
check my email and every time I used to
have notifications for every time I got
a subscriber and every time I would see
a notification pop up and a little name
saying that they subscribed me out just
my heart would just kind of bounce
around in my chest a bit and I was so
happy because some other person and I
would get like you know maybe 20 30
emails like that in a day and I just by
the time until you know on that hour oh
it's gonna happen and if it didn't
happen I go okay maybe next and then two
in the next hour I was so excited now
you know I kind of lose that little joy
of the happening because I had to turn
that off a long time ago or else I'd get
spammed by thousands of emails and I
used to do the same thing for comments
too you know every time those would
happen more frequently I would always
like those because I would read every
single one and that's something that I
that's the last thing that I lost when
the channel started growing I literally
can't read all the comments anymore
because some videos have I think the
most I saw was 3,000 comments in a
single video and I don't know about you
guys but my day would be totally
consumed by that and I'm trying to keep
up with emails and whatnot
but it's kind of sad to see it go but I
know it's gonna be worth it to see where
we're going to go you know and how the
channel will grow I didn't really need
stop rhyming now just so you know god no
okay oh look it's starting to snow
ah no okay oh okay all right so anyway
all in all it's sad to see some things
go that come with a smaller Channel
Ben if the potential benefit that
outweighs what there used to be is just
too high you can't escape that so I am
sad and in a lot of ways I miss the
personal aspect of it cuz he's even
these via logs used to be a lot more
personal and I would quite often just
reply to comments
or through my still do I still pour
through a lot I just can't do all of
them it's much easier when they're just
131 weird things like [ __ ] and mark is
great
penis reference and stuff like that but
there are a lot of really big meaningful
comments out there and I try to get to
some of those anyway I've been rambling
again so thank you guys so much for a
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
it's not even close to the end of the
ride but still God will remember these
things when they happen because if I
don't I forget why I've done this in the
first place so thank you guys again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye